hello and welcome to this video playing
+ + from Norway right it's not some
obscure know yeah sometimes you have
those obscure flags that are very
similar to a well-known 1d6 I know me go
nite f3m get the system so called the
vate variation and then take named after
Bob wait so what about this hmm quite
sure about the move water sometimes
night h6 is an idea here for black yeah
I wasn't sure if I can somehow prevent
that maybe I should have plenty to first
even though if I go Bishop d3 where it's
the night going it's not going to have 5
p.m. I assume
hmm ok let's see what he's doing I can
sometimes even though g4 uh-huh so hmm
so you're going back now or what exactly
to have five hmm yeah maybe you can play
that the pawn structure looks a little
bit strange but it's not I think it is
bad I wanted to say it's not so bad but
i think it is bad
yeah 98 cannot be the solution here so
so you have to go all night at five now
I guess now okay daddy five I think even
though yeah I think it's good and be
three I think or well cooney to is also
an idea it's not quite clear that b3 is
helping me a bit
I like that more my idea is to go Bishop
d4 and then f1 anyway or f4 and then
Bishop t4 I'd like to trade that Bishop
and yeah this is an interesting move I
was thinking about it and I wasn't quite
sure what to do now if I should just
take on do something else I think I'd
leave it as it is the e-file here with
potential f4 that should give me good
attacking ideas against a seven and dome
yeah I think it's okay not to take even
though capturing arguably also is
slightly better for wide ok let's just
step out of the g file let's not spend
too much time you're trying to search
for perfect moves if you have a good
move available
yeah it's probably going to Castle long
if I play F for now 94 very likely lead
to a trade mm-hmm right it's a good
position for a while still it's not
clear that i need to allow that yeah so
I was thinking f4 here h3 that's FY like
f for Bishop takes Knight f3 stuff like
that so no age 3 I think I'm going here
this is probably good for me so this and
I am taking with the rook
just piling up on his seven he has
Bishop f6 but I have night 92 g 3 and so
on well I can tell you though definitely
can double on the gphone can the prolly
wasn't so great yeah okay I didn't play
that well certainly not the best
possible outcome
it was a strategically very promising
position and this is yeah not not
entirely clear at least so what about
this if I go h4 can he see able to
sacrifice I don't think he can do that
should h4 shouldn't work same here also
should work I want to go to f3
ultimately I always have rook h3 for
example if he takes on edge for my D is
93 then possibly 95 or trying to to
operate with possible exchange sex only
seven night is best on f3 anyway
covering age fluent everything yeah I
think he tries to make the sacrifice
work but ultimately couldn't
so what about this well he went to e8
some hmm
it looks it looks very weakening if i go
to eat to hear i will see handling that
some e five maybe no i don't see that
working you cannot take as he ate hanks
so Bishop deform am now going to take
these sects that also wouldn't work
maybe it does with no it doesn't have
that this was just not good then I'm
winning winning some kind of material
hmm maybe you can go F for some
something something wild yes that's may
be possible okay so various ideas i also
have esox here e six also looks pretty
good Teague's root cheeks that looks
quite safe actually check material up
here and good control f6 and d6 is
hanging yeah it looks fine time same
thing I just he can take yeah I think
just grab left resign grass that
additional pawn here on age five and
then win with GNH pawn okay this was a
pretty good position out of the opening
that I actually didn't play well yeah I
have my doubts if you can really do that
here even geforce interesting this is
given by the engine by the way g4 and
then Queen d2 sending the night back
completely yeah that's a premium
pretty good move actually but but this
isn't bad I don't think it's bad at all
I'm forcing this structure which can
only be good for white and now yeah I
think be three is good and now it went
c5 yeah that's an interesting question
taking is not bad i'm pretty sure i
guess 90s and just here and this is also
a nice position i have that idea to
still put the knight on d5 if
circumstances are right e six is not so
easy to play to kick it out and I have
this display on the center of files
sometimes there's also the right moment
that you to play c5 and open it up it's
it's a comfortable for white but I
thought that this is even better and i'm
pretty sure that i have a very nice
position here but i couldn't really yeah
get get to something really good yeah
maybe this is too simple yeah my night
is not a good piece I I actually a
thought originally I would put it here
and the take at five but that didn't
work out this kind of thing now I I
simply don't get get around doing that
if i go here he will have the H porn
coming up for example and it's not clear
my night cannot move sg2 is under attack
so does it didn't seem right so i went
with this and simply blocked the King
side I mean still I feel like I'm a bit
better but it doesn't doesn't feel super
clear here can I g1 of course and he can
never sacrifice and i'll tt-take and i
always have some additional help Eon the
third-ranked yeah i know that that is
it's nice and now after me six I think I
should be clearly better yeah six is
good Mookie six crew can't stop fish
gives 1.5 check yeah I dare to plug a
decent game I thought I maybe I had
something more powerful here from this
position but um the engine didn't give
anything that was obviously much better
than what I did and it gave some
different moves but not with anything
spectacular in terms of eval so I'm
probably it can probably be be happy
with with the game okay thanks for
watching